here now the aforementioned Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire who
wrote today is five reasons why Oprah
would win and five reasons why she could
lose Ben good evening good to see as
always you know we thought that a
matchup between Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump was gonna be fascinating
and indeed it was but this this could be
a whole new level no question I mean
Oprah Winfrey is the most well known
person probably on planet earth the
outside of President Trump so you'd have
two of the most high-profile people in
American history battling it out she
obviously is another self-made
billionaire she has cultivated
particularly female audiences for the
last thirty years she's a television
star she has a really great personal
story on the other hand she is a
conspiracy theorist she is on the far
left and her image as sort of United not
a divider would certainly take a hit
were she to get political it's one thing
for president Trump who basically has
been hit with every piece of mud and
emerged unscathed to run for reelection
Oprah Winfrey is basically seen as this
almost angelic figure in American pop
culture and if she is hit at all with
any sort of scandal it may not affect
her quite the same way if you want to
move from a place where 90% of people
love you to a place where 50% of people
hate you quickly moving to politics yeah
I mean Donald Trump is certainly
witnessed that himself during his
transformation from being a private
citizen to being president of the United
States do you think you know when you
look at America as a society are we
living in a world where you almost have
to be a celebrity you look at all the
people who have thrown their names in
the ring and Mark Cuban Kanye West has
talked about it the rock has talked
about it and you know you start to
wonder if you're living in this sort of
you know freak freakish parallel
universe lately I think there's some
truth in it I think the idea that that
high name recognition makes a difference
particularly in primaries is absolutely
true can you imagine Oprah Winfrey
losing primaries to Joe Biden I can't I
think that if Oprah Winfrey runs against
a bunch of typical Democratic
politicians they have a very hard time
knocking her out of the race obviously
the Republicans couldn't knock down all
Trump out of the race and he was less of
a celebrity than Oprah Winfrey is I
think it's because Americans have this
sort of dual track mind when it comes to
what they think the president does on
the one hand we think that the president
is there to do policy and engage in
policy we like and then there's really
what we think the President does which
is say stuff
right when we think of people who say
stuff we tend to think of celebrities we
tend to think of the people who are on
our TVs all the time we think of these
people as sort of the the Fig
heads on the prow of the ship of state
and in that sense if there are people
who are very famous and we've already
made our decisions about them it's a lot
easier for them to survive the slings
and arrows than politicians we may not
have ever heard of and it can be taken
down with the single scandal remember in
2012 Rick Perry was basically knocked
out of the primaries because he had
mandated the Gardasil be use red a
vaccine for a particular type of cancer
for young girls that knocked him out of
the primaries in 2012 Donald Trump got
hit with everything including the
kitchen sink and he put the election you
know when you take a look at this
potential matchup you know you've got
Oprah Winfrey who I think would be so
embraced by Democrats that she probably
wouldn't be standing up there was 17
other candidates I mean you know when
when Donald Trump tried it
everyone just laughed at him they
thought he was he was not gonna last
wouldn't make it through the summer
wouldn't make it through the fall I mean
that's the very different dynamic here
Ben I think that's true and I think that
work rats also have a way of anointing
candidates that Republicans simply have
not had in 2016 obviously they anointed
Hillary Clinton in 2012 they thought
about in 2008 rather they thought about
anointing Hillary Clinton and then Oprah
Winfrey is the person who helped push
Barack Obama over that finish line so I
think the chances are actually pretty
good that if Oprah decided to run should
win the nomination in a general election
I do have my doubts as to whether she
would actually defeat the president the
last poll that I saw was from March and
it showed it showed Oprah defeating
Trump something like 47 to 40 but those
are incredible numbers for Oprah she has
I think 49 percent approval vs. 33
percent disapproval wait till she
actually has to go through a political
cycle or two and see how those numbers
hold up I got a leg up but one last
thing you sort of went out on a limb
today you said you don't think she was
that brave you know everybody on that
room was up on their feet and you said
she wasn't brave last night what did you
mean you know what the hell kind of risk
was she taking she was standing in front
of an entire town filled with sexual
abusers and her ass errs she said
nothing about it for 20 years she's
being shirred by people who said nothing
about it for 20 years and there she is
pretending that she's leading the fight
in what way has she led the fight I sort
of missed it and just because she said
some stuff last night I haven't seen how
things have materially changed I mean
Reese Witherspoon was mentioned that she
measures things before Oprah and after
Oprah what changed after Oprah Oprah
said a bunch of stuff well I was under
the impression that most of us agreed
with that stuff when this stuff first
broke and she routed the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association where were
they reporting on the sexual harassment
abuse scandal for the last 20 years it
is literally their job to cover
Hollywood and yet it took the
your car and Ronan Farrow to uncover all
this stuff where was the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association it was
receiving such plaudits at the hands of
Oprah Winfrey again a woman who was good
friends with Harvey Weinstein being
chaired by Meryl Streep a woman who
stands and gave a standing ovation to
Roman Polanski yeah there's a circle of
support that ignored everything that you
just mentioned so potently been thank
you very much great to see you tonight